there are basically three major power
systems roughly speaking North America
Europe and North East Asia now joined to
India and South Asia and to Southeast
Asia there are lots of integration among
them they're not distinct but they are
identifiable power centers a separate
from them are the major oil producers
which have no power but have a lot of
financial resources Europe and the
United States are roughly comparable in
every dimension except the military
force the United States its military
spending now exceeds substantially that
of the rest of the world combined and
nothing is even close the North East
Asia's probably the most dynamic
economic region in the world china-based
Japan South Korea its has amassed
enormous financial resources in fact
it's Japan China and some extent the oil
producers have been sustaining the US
economy how long they'll do it is
unclear the primary regions of this
plenty of violence all over the world
with the most extreme regions are the
Middle East region mainly because that's
the major energy these are the major
sources of energy for the world US
invasion of Iraq is the central part of
it but not the only one it's and it's a
very volatile area there could be a
confrontation between the US and around
US attack on Iran which one well-known
British military historian Corelli
Burnett I said that would be world war
three many could be right the there are
other tendencies developing South
America as you mentioned as thank you
for the first time in its history since
the Spanish invasion is making
significant moves towards integration
the society has been very countries and
they are separate from one another
they've been ruled by tiny wealthy
mostly Europeanized elites related to
the imperial societies not the one
another and they're moving towards a
degree of integration hence independence
and they're also beginning slowly to
tackle some of their immense internal
problems there's a huge inequality in
fact some of the most exciting
Democratic experiments may be the most
exciting are taking place right there
especially in Bolivia where the majority
of the population the indigenous
majority has for the first time entered
the political arena in a serious way
elected their own candidate from their
own ranks it's leading to a possible
threat of secession by the white
European eyes daily which has always run
the country and has most of the
resources there's plenty of sources of
conflict there but important develop
many wisdom in many ways the most
exciting area of the world I think
there's the bank of the south which is
broadly supported could be an
alternative development fund just as the
asian development bank could be theirs
what happens in China and India will be
of no doubt of enormous significance
there they do have a high growth rates a
a lot of people have been
taken out of poverty it should be
recalled that they've succeeded in doing
this largely by violating the rules of
rules of the game that are that the
Western powers have attempted to
establish that's no surprise to economic
historians because that's the way the
developed countries got rich themselves
but they're now significant players on
the world scene particularly China
however within extraordinary internal
problems hundreds of millions of people
either destitute or in serious serious
economic problems enormous ecological
problems India which has has developed
significantly in the last actually
starting in the 1980s but particularly
in the last 15 years still ranks that I
think about 125th or so in the United
Nations of Human Development Index is
seen of enormous poverty and destitution
but so they have tremendous internal
problems to deal with there nor near the
level of the rich developed Western
European and North American countries
but shifting power in the world seem
doubtless these are some of the China
happens to be the center of a developing
strategic system the Shanghai
Cooperation Organization which based in
China includes Russia with its quite
enormous energy resources and other
resources India and Pakistan and Iran
are associated they're admitted
observers the Central Asian states are
part of it the United States has sought
observer status but been rejected the
organization has called on the u.s. to
leave the the region central
asian other regions and this is a slowly
emerging power block that some regard is
potentially a counterpart the nato with
substantial internal resources russian
particularly but if it ran joins in even
more and reaching out towards the even
toward saudi arabia which is the jewel
in the crown as far as energy resources
are concerned doubtless a source of
enormous concern to the United States
which is trying pretty desperately to
set up a Sunni counter force and the
somehow control Iraq which is turned to
a total catastrophe the these are some
not all of the major live issues on the
global global scene
you
her